and shifting gears it is clear tonight
that a two-tiered system of justice is
Alive and Well in the country one
standard for well-connected Democrats
and their families and another for the
rest of us and God help you if your last
name's Trump but it's not just Biden his
VP Kamala Harris has had a heavy hand in
enforcing a two-tiered system of justice
as Tulsi gabbard once reminded her
during a Democratic primary debate Tulsi
joins us right now do you believe we
have a two-tier justice system
Sean is not a question of belief the
proof and the evidence is there and
we're seeing it play out right before
our very eyes where today's Democrat
Elite are showing very shamelessly that
they have no problem abusing their power
they're making a mockery of the rule of
law and undermining our democracy on the
one hand for example
they are throwing everything with the
kitchen sink and the kitchen sink at
Donald Trump doing all that they can
saying hey no one is above the law
trying their their hardest to destroy
him and make it so the voters don't even
have an option they won't even have the
choice to be able to vote for him in
this next election on the other hand you
look at this growing amount of of
damning undeniable evidence pointing to
Hunter Biden and the president United
States
corruption quid pro quo influence
trading the list goes on and on every
day it gets worse and yet what's the
Democrat Elites response Nancy Pelosi
says oh this is just a clown show
completely dismissing it not addressing
the very serious serious implications
that are coming about as a result of
this so you know the American people are
not stupid they see what is going on
right before our very eyes and how
dangerous it is for our country I I
tried to lay it out in very simple terms
so everybody can understand it at the
top of the show and and you're exactly
right I mean Joe said he didn't do he'd
never talked to his son about these
deals now we're learning that he was
actively involved in them uh obviously
probably benefited financially
um you said something the last time you
were on with us that intrigued me and I
asked you if you would consider or are
you considering running for president
I'm going to ask you the question a
different way are you considering it and
what is your reaction to the No Labels
group that is being formed that seems to
be really really flirting with the idea
of of having a third party candidacy
have you been approached by them are you
interested in them
I I know some of the folks that know
labels and and have worked with them on
different things both when I was in
Congress working with the problem
solvers caucus as well as looking at
this this effort that they're doing you
know when you have the Democrat Elite
running so scared and doing all that
they can to destroy No Labels effort
simply to provide the American people
with another option uh that should tell
us about what's what really is happening
here the Democrat Elite feel threatened
by their uh you know their power is
threatened and they don't care about the
American people having an option to to
be able to are you a candidate and or do
everything that they can to to oppose
them are you open to pursuing the
nomination through that venue
Sean it's not something I'm thinking
about right now as I've said to you
before my interest is where can I best
serve the American people I don't know
where that path will lead we'll see
okay would you consider running as a
Republican
we'll see where that path leads Sean I
have a feeling you're going to be one of
the first people I talk to I have the
feeling I'm going to be the the last
person that you tell because you're
ducking my question but uh we appreciate
you being here not at all all right